Well hello everybody.
It's day 4 reinvent and it's lunchtime,
so I'm so honored to have such a dedicated
audience. There's a lot
to learn today.
Um, we're also joined by an audience
out in Wyn
as well as the Venetian. So hello
from Mandalay Bay.
I'm Dylan Tong. I'm from OpenSearch
Product. I'm responsible for
AI and vector workloads. I'm joined
by my colleague.
Hello everyone, this is Wamshivijay Nirta
working as a senior software manager.
Uh, working on search at Amazon Open Search Service.
Hope you guys are having an amazing reinvent.
Yeah, so this session is about building billion
scale vector databases. We're
gonna be introducing two
reinvent launches for open
search GPU vector GPU acceleration
and auto optimize.
So with that said,
can I have a quick show of hands who here is currently
using OpenSearch?
All right, so a few of you, um,
any of you have experience with vector
search?
A couple, OK,
so we have,
um,
so we're gonna spend some time just a brief
moment to get everybody up to speed
for some of you maybe a refresher, but we're
gonna keep it succinct,
OK?
So quickly open search, it's a
search and analytics engine. It's
Apache open source, it's part of the
Linux Foundation.
And on AWS
there's a couple of flavors. One, managed clusters
where you have full control of selecting your
instances. We provide automation
to provision those clusters as well
as operational functionality.
And then there's a serus version,
right, with auto scaling.
And such
there's peripheral services,
open search ingestion for you
to, uh, process and
load your data into open search
and open search dashboards
for visualizations.
People use OpenSearch for a lot of things, but
there's really kind of two main use cases. There's
one half that uses it for log analytics
and observability,
and then the other half is search, which is the focus
of this presentation today.
It could be keyword search, it's
vector search, as well as a hybrid,
a blend of the two.
Don't worry if you're not familiar with vector
search, we'll get you up to speed, but for
now, just know, hey, why do people use
vector search.
Foremost, it's simply to improve search quality,
vector hybrid variance, it's the state
of the art.
It's also very uh versatile,
right? It supports text-based
search, but you can search
audio images
across between the two.
There are also diverse applications,
the obvious ones being semantic search,
but also you can use vector
search for recommendations, personalization,
anomaly detection as well.
Talk more about this, but it's also a key ingredient
in agentic applications.
A lot of people are surprised
about our history, our long history in vector
search. Did you know
we began our journey back in February 2020.
It actually predates the birth of open
search. We contributed something
called the KNN
K nearest neighbor plug-in
to the elastic open distro.
And it wasn't until 2021 where
OpenSearch 1.0 was released, this
was a fork of Elastic Search
7.10.
And with that also, you
know, built an Apache Luce,
so we inherited
a wide breadth of advanced search
capabilities from that foundation.
We already had
a growing number of vector search
users,
some very large scale,
you know, for example, folks in Amazon pushing
the envelope, retail,
Amazon Music, Amazon recognition
use cases back then were around like image
search and a lot of personalization,
um, but we wanted to uplevel
our scalability with 1.0,
so we integrated Face,
which is Meta's vector search library
well known for performance and scale.
I think we all remember 2023, right? That
was the year of Gen AI,
and with that there was the, the buzz around
vector database, right? It's vector
database instead of like KNN.
So we
brought our vector search capabilities
to open search Servius.
We became the default for Amazon
Bedrock knowledge bases where people
can, you know, build on bedrock foundation
models and agents and
reg retrieval augmented generation.
We created something called hybrid
search, so out of the box you can
blend the traditional lexical
keyword search with vector search which turns
out improves search quality.
We started thinking
beyond vectors as well, you know, how
can we create
an AI native search engine. So
we built these connectors, integrations
to third party services, open AI.
Uh, cohere as well as Amazon
StageMaker and Bedrock so that we
can automate the generation of vectors.
Throughout the year, the deployment started getting
bigger, so it became a priority to help our
customers reduce costs.
Cost optimizations was top of mind,
building disk optimizations,
tiered storage,
um, automatic quantization.
word for basically compression capabilities
and we continue our journey around ease of use
and AI native functionality.
So not just vectors but general AI enrichments
like language detection,
translation, and other automated metadata
extraction.
So today in 2025, naturally
cost optimization
continues to be a priority.
AI Native, we built agentic and AI
search flows into our engine.
We have MCP integration, but
there was a new theme.
Deployments are getting larger and larger,
so a new theme we doubled down on
empowering scale, and that's to focus on
a conversation.
Two new features focus on
customers coming to us.
We're growing, we're, we're building bigger vector
databases. We like open search, but
help,
please make it faster, easier, and cheaper
to scale your vector database.
So before we talk about these two features, let's
take a look at cus a couple of customer examples
and that trend towards billion scale.
As mentioned before, we
already had large scale customers early on 2020.
Example of that, right, is
Amazon brand protection.
So this is the unit
within Amazon that protects our customers
and partners, our retail customers and, and
partners from abuse,
and so they have a large number
of automated systems in the
background to detect things like IP infringement
anomalies throughout the entire product catalog.
So they take the entire catalog,
they basically vector encoded it
into 68. Billion vectors
and they're running an automation system
on open search
searching for anomalies potential IP
infringement and it's
this among you know other automation
capabilities enables us to
detect abuse
before 99% of them are
even reported.
So early days,
a lot of the scale was driven
by, you know, the likes of like Amazon,
but today it's prevalent.
Um, and part of that trend
you probably heard it if you've been to the AI
talks, right, is agentic
applications, more and more customers
building agentic features into
their apps, and a good example of that is a
startup called Devrev AI. We've been
working with them
for about a year now.
So Devrev,
they have this product they call a computer
and just think about it as your AI
teammates.
The challenge or the problems they're helping
their their customers to solve,
it's an age-old one nothing special. It's
about everybody has siloed
enterprise data sources, right, and
tools, and they're looking to bring it together.
But they're rethinking it, they're reimagining it,
how we can better solve the problem with
AI agents to connect,
unify the data sources,
drive search and automation.
OK,
so, and, and they're, and basically
they're driving it specifically across
product support,
sales,
and
product management.
They built it on open search. Today
hundreds of millions of vectors.
And a million vectors
changing on a daily basis, so growing
really rapidly,
um, already great successes with their
customers in support, uh, they've
achieved, um, 88, I think%
of their 85% of their
tickets are resolved without human interaction,
you know, 30%
cost reduction in customer support, saving
their customers a lot of time.
Let's dive a little bit deeper into
the components of agentic systems.
So imagine we have a travel system,
right? Agentic features allow us,
give us a conversational interface that you can
perhaps request. Help me plan my trip
to
reinvent 2025.
That request gets processed by an AI agent,
typically large language model.
It creates an execution
plan usually you'll then reach out
to knowledge bases,
uh, application history for context,
and then compile
some automation, perhaps
putting together like a travel itinerary in this
case, well.
You know what the saying goes, garbage in
garbage out. So when it reaches out to
the knowledge bases, let's say in this case
hotel venues,
flights,
if it's not able to retrieve
the, you know, high quality search
results, you're gonna exact you're gonna
expect poor.
Responses and automation
vector search is the state of the art.
Let's take a look at the example to understand why
that's the case.
So here I'm running a search
on a wiki data set.
I'm searching for wild west,
and you see on the left hand side
keyword search, it's returning
results like
the West Virginia basketball team because
it's keying in on the term West.
On the right hand side it's semantic
search using a vector based implementation.
And I'm getting like cowboys and rodeos because
vector search is matching on semantic
similarity
and I'm getting much better results.
So if we're gonna build
high quality agentic features,
we need to
build these vector databases or run
vector search across our vast
enterprise data sources that
requires scale.
But easier said than done, there
are a lot of challenges, some of you may know,
to scaling your vector database.
Let's get everyone up to speed on the basics.
Highest level you start with your
content you have an embedding model
that's specially designed to encode
that content
into vectors
and then open search provides APIs
for you to ingest and
build an index on those vectors
and then that enables you
to then run search queries
like similarity search queries on
that content.
But what are those vectors exactly?
The vectors are the same vectors that
you learned back in physics and linear
algebra,
right? Main difference is back then is, you know,
X, Y, Z, typically 3 dimensions.
These vectors are typically over 1000
dimensions these days, but they're just a
long list of numerical values.
But what's interesting is that these vectors
that are encoded by these embedding models,
when you measure the distance between the two, that
represents a degree of similarity.
So imagine I had a music
corpus. I got two music tracks
coded into vectors. If I measure, let's
say the cosine or the Euclidean distance,
that's the degree of similarity between those
two songs.
If we take,
if we, we do take those vectors and we just
superimpose it into two dimensions
so that we can visualize it, it's gonna look something
like, um, this
scatter graph.
And this arrow, pretend that's
your favorite song it's been encoded to
a vector
basically the area around
that vector,
those are similar songs, the most similar
songs and perhaps
the songs that you may be interested
in. That's
how vector search works.
So you have things turned into vectors, you
can measure similarity, how do you run
search queries?
Couple of ways.
So the first one is brute force exact.
So imagine you have a query vector, that's your favorite
song, it's a vector.
And then you have the rest of the music
corpus,
um, all the songs, they're all vectors as well,
and literally
if you find a top K, you know, maybe
top 100, top 10 top K
songs known as
K nearest neighbors,
I literally do a comparison between
everything. That query vector, compare
it to one song,
measure the distance,
and then figure out which ones are the most closest
together. Obviously that takes a very long
time when you scale to a billion, it's
gonna take, you know,
minutes at least to run a query.
And that's why we have indexes.
So we have these algorithms,
popular one like
hierarchical navigable navigable small
worlds, HNSW. There's other algorithms
where you preprocess these vectors
and you build these graph-like structures that you see
here. And once you have this index,
you can then do real-time queries. I
can now run that top que query
in milliseconds. It traverses this graph.
It gets the results for you.
Um, the trade-off mainly is it's a
lot of heavy duty processing to build that index
up front and it's also approximation,
but the approximation of exact canon is generally
very close, right? You can get 0.99
or higher.
OK, so what does open search do exactly
with the indexes? So it does build these indexes,
but it does more to scale,
um, so open search,
the way it scales is it basically
creates a search cluster. It runs across
a whole bunch of servers,
a whole bunch of instances.
So think about billion,
a billion vector corpus.
It's distributing it,
partitioning it across a whole bunch of
servers,
and we build these indexes and
host them,
provide security and management.
Right across all these data partitions
and these indexes when you run a search
query, what's happening is in parallel
it's traversing all these indexes
across all these servers and that's how it's possible
to deliver millisecond search queries
on a billion scale vector data set.
So that's managed clusters on the left hand
side. Servius on the
right. The architecture you can see is more fancy,
but the con the concept in terms of how we're
scaling vector search is the same right across
servers.
The only difference here is what you're seeing is the search
and the indexing workloads are separated
and storage and compute separated,
and this is how it enables more auto
scaling,
um, capabilities, but
same type of scaling.
So
great, we could scale, we've always been able
to scale, but like I said, these indexes
they require a lot of memory, a
lot of compute, more so than traditional database
indexes or traditional search indexes.
I'm curious for the folks
especially who don't have experience. I mean, what, what would
you expect? I mean, do you,
do you think that if I were to build
a 1 billion scale index,
who thinks it should take, shouldn't take
more than half a day.
Who thinks it shouldn't take more than half a day?
OK, I probably gave it away. I
probably gave it away, but yes, it takes
more than half a day.
Generally in the wild it takes
days.
So that's tough, right,
in terms of productivity and your innovation
velocity. Typically in the wild,
lots, there's variables, but it typically
takes days.
And the catch is, is not just a one
time thing. It's not like build the index, you know, OK, it's
gonna take a couple of days, it's just a one time
thing. There's a life cycle to it. These
indexes are special.
Um, you have to rebuild them more often than your
traditional database index.
So first of all, HNSW,
it does degrade when the data changes. So you have an agentic
app. It's very dynamic, right? The
vectors, the content is changing all the
time. Well, you're gonna have
you, you gotta mitigate
the search quality degradation and
rebuild that index
if you change that embedding model
as well, it means you're gonna have to regenerate
the vectors and rebuild that index.
So you know when can that happen? You know,
maybe you're switching between OpenAI
and Tropic cohere.
OK, you're gonna have to rebuild that index,
um.
These vendors, they
produce multiple versions of
their model every year that happens, you know, 1
to 4 times I think typically per year.
You wanna benefit from the latest and greatest,
you're gonna have to
update, rebuild your index,
but it could be even more frequent than
that,
especially for special use cases, maybe like
personalized search,
taking an example from Amazon Music.
So Amazon Music is a streaming
service
and when you see.
If you've used it before,
you may see, hey, um,
because you listen to this song we
think he may be interested in these other songs
that is powered by vector search
so they have this recommender type model
it's built for vectors generates vectors
from um their song
selection, all the older music tracks.
Over a billion vectors running
an open search and they use
that to power that rec those recommendations.
If you're familiar with
recommendations personalizations,
it's important
for you to continually
retrain or fine tune those models
on your users' latest behaviors
and profiles if you wanna have the
best recommendation.
Foundations their case need to do it on a daily
basis so there's these use cases
you have to rebuild the indexes on
a daily, weekly, or monthly basis
depending on your use case. What happens if that
takes days? It's gonna be tough making your SLA
or it's gonna be a burden.
Also
For those you know on the managed cluster, your
search and your indexing workloads are also
running on that same infrastructure.
Well, you have these graphs
that take a lot of
RAM, a lot of compute, and
at the same time you're running search,
there's a tug of war going on right
for these resources.
And there's gonna then be also the challenge
right operationally to maintain good
search times.
So there's also that challenge,
right, in terms of separation of workloads.
So these are the problems that our customers are
facing at large scale,
uh, vector search systems.
Building, maintaining them take days.
It's tough to maintain,
right? A vector ingestion can impact
search speed.
So we need to help our customers
maintain their innovation velocity,
their productivity,
and build responsive
applications.
So we knew that one
potential solution could be GPU,
right? So we all know GPU
from things like computer graphics,
right, in gaming
and AI
and what's going on in those cases, it's
a lot of vector math
it's really good at that,
so we knew that there's a lot of potential, so we worked,
which is the same as what's going on with vector
search
and building these indexes
so we worked with Nvidia.
And Nvidia has this library
called QVS bunch of vector
algorithms optimized
for GPU.
And
we worked with them to explore things like they
had this algorithm called CAR.
And so we looked at that.
And we worked with them on enhancements as well
because we wanted to be able to
build on Kagara
but we wanna run those indexes in
RAM, right, and run search in RAM still
so we can run other workloads.
So we worked with them on enhancements in
that area
and we want it to run in face so build
on CR,
transfer to RAM, run within Meta's
face libraries.
With those enhancements, we also ran a whole bunch
of tests that you see here,
uh, data set sizes running from 1
million, 10 million,
100 to 1 billion different
vector
data set sizes.
So we start off by creating first
a baseline, right? Let's just run it on CPU.
We build the index,
uh, we run a something called a merge
command if you're familiar with it, but that's important basically
you build the index and with, uh,
Lucine, right,
you need to do a merge to ensure that the
afterwards the index has high search
performance.
So we include that in the test and you can see
here. It takes a long time. Once
you get to the large scale, the 100
to the 1 billion cases, it now takes over
a day to perform that on
a right size cluster.
What happens when we add a GPU
instances into the mix.
Huge difference.
See a speed up ranging from 6
to 14 times.
And
there's also.
The cost of building that index, the
cost of that tax, uh, building
that index of task
is also much lower cost because it's
doing it so much faster
and so much more efficient
even though we're, we have more infrastructure. Not
only do we have a CPU infrastructure, but we
added
additional GPU infrastructure, so it's
more, but because it does the task so
much faster and so much more efficient,
you can see cost savings from 6
to 12x
substantial.
The cost savings are a little bit more um
easier to understand from a servalist standpoint. Remember
I said that
the search and the indexing workloads
are separated on serval list.
So what that means is that when you get your bill from
Servius, you actually see a line item that says
these are your index this is your index cost.
This is your search cost
and in along with that cost
it's gonna say, OK, you use this many OCU
hours that's open search compute
units.
So with the same test, basically you're seeing
let's look at the 113 million case
1,024 dimensions.
It's saying that you use 2,721
OCU hours. That's a lot.
It's basically a lot just to build that
big index.
Well, when we add GPU and
I converted the GPU
cost to OCU so it's kind of easy to
understand
again we're adding GPU infrastructure,
but it's reducing the
CPU utilization
and again it's tremendous
so if we look at the.
113 million
test case we brought that down
to 104.5 OCUs
to accomplish that task.
That's 8.9 times
um cost reduction to put that
in hard numbers
in US uh
North Virginia, the cost for one OCU
hour is 24 cents. If we do the
math, basically we're going from.
Um, was it $853
to $73. That's huge. Now it's,
now it's manageable, right? If you're at
that scale you have to rebuild the indexes. Now
the cost is,
is manageable.
The other thing I want to look at is.
We want to simulate a dynamic
application. Now I think we have agentic
app. We have a whole bunch of concurrent
users are searching for things,
but at the same time they're also updating,
inserting content, so we're, we're
indexing at the same time.
To set the search speed can be impacted. So
this test is demonstrating that, right? We're doing
a mixed workload,
mixed workloads on the Y axis. This is
indexing clients. Just think of that we're ramping
up
the number of writers, like the amount of
updates and indexing operations on the
system,
and in the line what we see is expected
the CPU utilization on a cluster
is increasing.
And
the bar graph is showing that the
search latency as a result is
increasing because there's a pressure
competition between CPU
and RAM between the reason rights.
When we add GPU and we offload
the CPU,
right, we bring down the CPU utilization
and the search latency now becomes
much more manageable, you know, now
it's a much better user experience,
you know, we're back to
good latency.
So
We saw we proved it out,
hey, a lot of potential for
GPU, but there's one more challenge,
exactly how are we gonna integrate
GPU into open search?
The obvious thing is, OK, we just
support GPU instances, right? That's the obvious,
that'll be really easy, but
if we did that,
that would cause
economic problems. Let's take a look at an example.
Let's say we did that.
Let's take a look at a
deployment
for 1 billion vectors, 1,0024
dimensions.
We're gonna apply aggressive
cost optimizations.
We use binary quantization, basically
32X compression.
To make the cluster as small as possible
on CPU.
What that means is that we have, it's
gonna be memory bound generally we need 3X,
you know, more than a terabyte of RAM,
right, for good performance.
So
we use 3 of these um
R R R 8 instances.
OK, so that's gonna cost some amount.
So let's say if I wanted to bring GPU, I'm
gonna have to pick a GPU instances in, you
know, use GPU instances.
We use the G6s because those are very
cost effective, but they're not
optimized for RAM capacity.
So I need 6 of those now
to meet the RAM requirements. That's 2.4
times the cost.
I got GPU now that's great, but
it's, it's a huge premium
for the speed gains
and I'm not always indexing so that's the
problem.
So we knew that we for this to be
practical for most of our customers we have
to do things differently.
So working backwards from the ideal scenario
is wanna let you continue using
your existing collections and domains
with, you know, running on your CPU
instances
you wanna use the same APIs we don't wanna change
any of that, but let's,
can we bring the GPU
to your CPU based clusters.
Only when you need it,
and you only pay for value, only when
you benefit
from the indexing, the GPU acceleration.
And we did that, we did just that. Exactly
how did we do it behind the scenes
we built the system that you see here,
so number one.
That's you as a user. There's no change
to how you
use open search
your indexing vectors, same thing, use the
index API to reindex bulk.
But what happens is when you have it enabled.
And we detect that now you
have high write throughput, let's say you're writing 10,000
vectors per second,
it's gonna trigger a configurable threshold.
And we are then going to allocate
GPU instances
to your CPU cluster offload
those graph builds.
We behind the scenes are gonna
manage a warm pool of GPU
instances for you. You don't need to worry about
that. Multi-tenant
because you then benefit from the economies
of scale,
but we do a single tenant secure
assignment,
so that you know it's only your workloads
running on those instances.
We scale, basically scale automate
the scaling for you when you're
done with the GPU acceleration we
return it to that pool
so we do all that behind the scenes
so that you only
need to pay
for what you benefit from.
From your standpoint
it's as simple as a light switch.
You just enable it through the APIs,
CLI through the console like you
see here,
and you pay
it's serless.
Doesn't matter if you're using managed clusters
or open source erus this acceleration
it's serless GPU
and it's at 24
cents basically per per OCU
hour. In North Virginia,
so, um, pretty much same
as the standard indexing OCUs.
So that's it, GPU accelerate vector indexing,
building these indexes much faster, but there's
actually more
to it
to create these,
um,
production systems.
So
with that.
My colleague is gonna talk about,
you know, what else we need to do.
Thanks, Julian.
So my colleague has covered about the basics
of vector database, generating the vectors,
ingesting the vectors, and building these indexes,
so we can enable the real-time vector search
for the end customers.
But
There is more to it.
There's one more important aspect in this flow. Can
anyone guess?
It's the index configuration
and optimizing the configuration.
So to build any vector index,
you need index configuration.
This index configuration determines
the search quality,
cost and speed
of your indexes,
of your applications.
And optimizing these indexes
can cut down the cost by 1/3 of the total cost,
and this is more evident as the scale of
the vector workload increases.
So let's
take a look at the scale.
So, on the X-axis, I have the number
of vectors.
On the y axis, I have the memory footprint.
As you see,
from 10 million onwards,
the memory footprint reduction is almost 75%.
So at 10 million, we almost see around 300
gigabytes of memory footprint savings.
At a billion scale,
we are able to see around 3 terabytes of
memory footprint savings.
So it's very important to optimize this index configuration.
Well, What are these index
configurations?
So Amazon Open Search Service
has a rich feature set of index
configurations
and its tunable parameters.
That lets our customers make a very smart
trade-off between
what should be my quality, cost,
and speed.
So on x-axis, we have the search quality,
which we call recall. On the y-axis we have the latency.
As we trade off between this quality
and the latency,
you could see those purple bubbles, all of those
are index configurations,
and each index configuration
have attunable parameters.
On a high level
you can think of these tunable parameters into like 3
categories. One category helps to determine
the type of algorithm. Is it like HNSW,
as Dylan talked about it?
That's graph-based algorithm.
And another one is IVF, which is a bucket-based
algorithm.
Similarly, the second kind of category is
the compression techniques
like do you need a binary quantization, scalar
quantization,
product quantization.
Like you can achieve the compression from 2X all
the way to 664X,
which helps you trade off
the quality for the memory footprint.
Similarly, the third category talks about the mode
of operating these graph data structures.
Do you want them
in memory
or on disk
or somewhere remote like S3 S3 vectors.
It helps you trade off the latencies.
Our customers love these trade-offs.
It helps them
get the best of their hardware resources,
but. It's not straightforward,
right? It needs some expertise
in KNN vector search algorithms,
and also
it takes time.
So,
the experts
would generally start with
picking up the configuration.
Algorithm configuration, the quantization technique,
and the mode of operating these algorithms.
And then you would run,
you would build, build these indexes,
have your ground truth, so you would evaluate
what is my quality,
latency.
And then the cost
And if it doesn't meet your requirements,
We adjust and repeat.
So this can take time.
Let's take an example.
So let's say I'm building an application which
needs 95% accuracy.
So I pick up a 32 X compression, the
binary quantization is very popular.
And I build my indexes, I run my quality
check, and then I realize, oh, it's 90%,
it's not 95%.
So
maybe I should reduce my compression level
so I can preserve more vector precision
and I can get better quality.
Uh, but the trade-off is in the memory.
I might need to pay more memory, so
I'll go back,
reduce my compression techniques to 16X,
and then rerun the builds
and then validate what is my recall quality.
Maybe this time it's 93% but still not
meeting my requirement.
I go back and then make it 8X, so on and so
forth. I repeat this process, build the
index, and validate my configuration
to check whether it meets my requirements or not.
And one more important aspect.
There is no one optimal configuration
that works for all the use cases.
The index configuration.
Is determined is is more subjected
to the data set and the business requirements.
So let's, let's take an example.
So let's say I'm building
a recommendation systems for an e-commerce
application. I need a high
performance vector database.
The quality has to be better.
The latency has to be near single digit or
double digit milliseconds.
So I would need something like the hyperparameterss.
It could be like in memory,
and then I have a NSW algorithm and
different parameters.
And similarly, I have another application where
I'm building a search
application for my company internal
for internal usage.
I need quality, but I don't need a single digit
millisecond.
Even 100 millisecond or 200 milliseconds is
fine. So then
accordingly, I'll choose, choose my hyperparameterss
configurations,
or maybe you're trying to have something
in between,
right? So,
arriving at these optimal configurations
takes time.
So
how did we simplify this?
So Amazon Open Search Service
wants to simplify the onboarding experience.
Whether you may be building.
Apiboy or
A large vector workload
we need to we wanted to reduce the
expertise needed to build and manage these indexes.
So what we did is we built an auto optimization
framework
and we let the framework learn all of these techniques,
all of these algorithms, parameters,
the tuning configurations, so we could do
the heavy lifting for you.
So now it gets simplified.
All a customer needs to provide is
what is my acceptable search quality
and what is my acceptable search
latencies.
And behind the scenes,
Amazon Open Search Service
will take your data, will take your business
requirements, analyze your vectors,
run a bunch of hyperparameter optimization
jobs,
and get you the recommendations.
And the good thing is
we also provide you
the, the, we are very transparent. We provide you
all the details, we provide you a detailed
report for each of the recommendation.
You can look at your performance metrics like what is
my recall,
what is my memory footprint,
you can look at your algorithms, algorithm
parameters, hyperparametters, compression
levels. So all the focus can now
be on the recommendations
and then you can pick up your best recommendation.
And
The best part
Our customers don't have to manage the infrastructure.
Amazon Open Search Service has a serverless
auto optimization framework. It's built on a serverless fleet
where we paralyze
all of our hyper optimization jobs.
And we build it under an hour.
Under 1 hour we are able to build the optimizations.
We are able to provide you the recommendations, optimizations
as recommendations.
So with this
one. We cut
off the expertise required.
All we need to do is to focus on the business
requirements.
2. We cut down
the time.
We are able to give your recommendations under
an hour, so all the iterations that you
need to do for a POC.
So we are doing it behind the scenes
for you. So under an hour you get your recommendations,
and 3,
they're cutting down the cost.
You don't have to manage the infrastructure
needed to run these experiments, the
POC, to get to the production.
Let's see it in action.
OK. So
Once you land on your open search service,
On the left hand side under the injection,
we added a new entry, vector injection.
For the purpose of the demo.
I'm going to play a role of a search engineer
who is trying to upgrade
application from a lexical search
to a semantic search like vector search.
So, I have the work, we have the workflow
explaining the process here.
Step one is preparing data set.
So I have all my documents. It could be text,
image, audio,
or video.
So we take all of the documents.
Pass it to the embedding models,
generate the vectors.
And have them in the S3 bucket.
Then step 2
I provide my business
requirements.
So I need
X search quality and Y latency,
so I provide the recommendations.
And step 3.
We would have the recommendation. I provide the requirements,
and step 3, we would have the recommendations
available.
And step 4.
I can choose one of the recommendations
and say build index.
So we ingest and accelerate the
building process.
With GPU acceleration.
So let's,
uh, let's do it, let's create one injection job.
So let's say when at step one,
we have to configure the data source and destination.
So my data source is an S3
bucket
and it's in
US East one. So within this, I
have the data folder.
So let me select my
uh folder.
And then I need to provide the destination details.
So this could be your Amazon open search domain
or Amazon open search
uh collection.
So,
let's, I'm going to pick up my domain.
So I'm going to pick up.
Of the domain and then you configure the permissions.
And then go to the 2nd step
as part of the 2nd step.
I configured my index.
So here,
I have my vector field named train.
And my space type is inner product,
and the dimension is 768.
So this particular thing has to match
with what we have in the S3 bucket.
So when we generate those embeddings from the
model. So I'm trying,
I'm, I'm putting the name of those vectors as train
and then having the embeddings there. So the mapping would be something
like train and then the vector
and the dimension of the vector is 768.
And the space type you could determine from the model
when you run it, so it tells you what is
the space type.
And then this is the best part of this. So here I
focus on the requirements.
So like I said, if I'm building
an application which needs a, which needs high
performance, I would choose something like 0.95
recall
and,
and how fast,
fast means within a single digit or under 50
milliseconds latencies.
So it's like a high performance application.
Similarly, if I want to build something like a chart
application, maybe this quality 90% quality
is good and it could be modest,
modest, so it's more like a balanced,
uh, profile.
So, accordingly, based on your
application, you could provide the requirements on
this page.
And, and then here you could review
your you can review the configuration.
And then click create.
So,
once you click on this button, so we are
sending a signal to our back end system.
To run the optimization, hyper optimization
jobs, hyperparameter optimization jobs,
and provide the recommendations.
So this would take
between 30 minutes to 1 hour.
So for the purpose of the demo,
I already had a job that is run, so I'll,
let me, uh, show the
recommendations from that job.
So once the job is complete, so you would have
a banner saying it's completed. It says that
you are in which step of the workflow.
So right now, I am at the recommendation step.
So
this is how my recommendations would look like. So
I have 3
recommended configurations.
It took 42 minutes to run this job,
and the,
the configurations, the business configuration
business requirements were 90% recall
and fast.
So
When we project our recommendations, we always
optimize them based on the cost, so we
sort them based on the cost.
The first recommendation.
Is a baseline for us.
So we're able to achieve 92
uh around uh yeah, 0.9
to recall.
And uh then between
option 2 and option 3, I'm able to get
more recall, but there is an increase in the memory
footprint. So this is the trade-off I
need to make
uh to get a 0.5%
uh better quality.
Will I, will I be OK to have 50%
memory footprint?
Or maybe I need 3% more better
recall, and I'm OK for having a 100%
memory footprint.
A 2X memory footprint.
So,
you can look at the performance metrics on this page.
And let's say you want to understand what
was actually the process,
what were the algorithms options that were picked
up behind each of these recommendations.
You can also look at the detailed report.
So you can click on the report.
So you can look at the engine parameters.
The mode
and the engine. So here we are picking up in memory
because
the business requirement was fast.
So to make it a single digit millisecond or
a double digit, we have to host the vector
data structures in the memory.
And then we are using the fires algorithm
and And files library
and the algorithm is HNSW. So here we, we
talk about all the hyperparametters that we picked up
and the value of the parameters
and what each parameter means.
So on a high level, HNSW has different
parameters like M EF construction,
EF search.
Which talks about
how many edges I need to establish between the nodes
or how many neighbors I need to consider
while I'm walking through the graph.
So the more the neighbors, the better the quality,
the more the edges, the better the quality,
but at the cost of memory footprint.
So these are all the evaluations we do behind the scenes
and come up with these parameters.
And then here we are using the binary quantization technique,
the 32X compression.
So essentially we are taking your dimension, which is 32
bit floating vector,
and making it to a single bit.
So likewise, I can go to different
recommendations
and then look at the configurations,
the engine parameters, algorithm parameters,
the compression parameters. So here it's using 16X
compression. So
So that's why, uh, the memory footprint has
been increased because previously the, the baseline
is using 32X,
but the second option,
we're able to recommend you the 16X compression
because it gives you around 0.3% better
recall. So
we look at all these options, the recommendations, and
for me and for my application,
uh, I'm, I'm willing to have option one
because my
accuracy requirement was 90%. This
is well above my requirement and uh
it is fast,
so I'm going with option one.
And then you click on the build index.
So as part of the index,
provide the name of the index.
So this is the index which we are going to
create on your destination.
So on the uh like in this case I have chosen
the Amazon open search domain. So
on that particular domain
I'm going to create this index
with the following configuration, the option one.
So finally, all the,
the configurations that we see in the report,
it boils down to the JSON,
uh, configuration. So this is how it looks
like it talks about the files.
It talks about this construction parameters
in our product. It talks about this compression
level in memory,
yeah. So we are able to finally get to the.
Jason, which OpenSearch can understand.
And let's say along with vector fields,
you also have other fields. Maybe you have
some metadata
like text, date, you can add
your fields here.
So let's say I have a field text.
So I'm going to
add a text field. Similarly,
I have a date field.
So on. So you can add your fields,
and this is, so when you're ingesting,
you look for these fields
on your documents in a 3 bucket.
And then
I can click build index.
The most important thing here is the GPU acceleration.
So, as my colleague talked about, so this
building these graphs are computer intensive operations.
So one part of it is ingesting into the destination,
but the second part is once it arrives at
the destination, the GPU acceleration
speeds up the building process,
so we can enable the search applications faster.
So you could enable from here.
So it takes you to the edit cluster page,
and then under the vector database features, we
have the option to enable or disable the acceleration.
So for this particular destination, I already had it
enabled.
So,
I can enable this, and then
click on Dryden.
So I need to choose a new generation instance
type. And that's it.
So the dry run,
it, it evaluates all the configurations,
just make sure that everything is correct, and then
it clicks the update process where
the flag gets enabled.
And then you can click on the build index.
So,
once we click on the build index,
what happened behind the scenes is
We kick off the ingestion workflow.
So we have an injection pipeline.
That takes the source, in
this case your S3 bucket,
the sink,
which is our destination, which is our domain or
a collection. And
then stream the data.
And the injection pipeline is also serverless,
so it can,
uh, based on your volume of your data
and based on how much your destination can,
can take, it can increase or decrease
the computing units.
And then once the injection is done,
so you can look at all the job configurations
here, you can go to the vector injection page.
And then look at all the completed jobs here.
So, For that optimization,
there are multiple states like completed and
then active
or failed
for the injection status.
Right now, I just, I, I just triggered the injection,
so it's in the creating state.
And then it becomes active.
And once the injection is completed,
we stop the pipeline.
So
With this,
We are able to,
within a few clicks,
we are able to
take your data,
take your business requirements.
Run the hyperparameter optimization jobs
under an hour.
Provide you the recommendations
so you can look at your recommendations
and choose the best recommendation.
And then within a single click
we are able to take the index configuration,
create an index,
and stream your data to the destination
all behind the scenes without having to, uh,
without any manual intervention.
So this is how without optimization
and the GPU acceleration features,
we had tried to simplify the onboarding experience
for Amazon Open Search Service.
So this concludes my demo.
I think we have some time to maybe take a few
questions a little bit early. What do you think?
Yeah, and
yeah.